now and turn our attention from the nfl
game to the college game
unlv is turning all sorts of heads this
year
nothing covet related but recruiting
related john treach now joins us tonight
as we
talk about unlv recruiting and john boy
the rebels turning heads with some of
these recruits they're getting
yeah chris you know recruiting rankings
can be ridiculous but people look at
them unlv is currently number one in the
mountain west according to 24 7 sports
in a time where you can't see players in
person this feels like a zoom national
title barry switzer oklahoma's great
coach and legendary living room salesman
once said
it's not about the x's and o's it's
about the jimmies and joes
and for marcus arroyo right now it's
about the aarons anthony's nicks and
jalen's
in the past seven days unlv has landed
six commitments
the program's most prodigious recruiting
weekend in history the rebels rookie
coach has connected and cultivated a
brand
rebel vision 2021 recruiting season is
like a trailer
and this crop of prospects has brought
out the hollywood production
so with that being said within the next
three to four years
i'll be attending to the university of
las vegas
baby but the name that may mean the most
aaron holloway from legacy high school
the first las vegas
to stay home everybody left everybody's
going to other places like usc
oregon and places like that and i feel
like it'll be good
for me to stay home and make some from
where
i came from for a program not
particularly proud of its past
the future is full of momentum
interestingly enough the postponement of
the high school sports season has many
prep stars committing early
unlv is seizing the opportunities chris
hey joe let me ask you
of course you and i'll be getting lots
of pats on the back right now for what
they're doing outside the state a lot of
coaches players parents
wondering what about these local
recruits and how is unlv
what they doing to keep the kids here in
vegas yeah you're right chris they are
selling it well
outside they're doing really well in
california southern california
particularly also
in texas but the key is i went back and
looked there are 13 kids who have
committed
from the following class from las vegas
only one
is staying home but that one can be a
domino aaron holloway from legacy a
great player
an excellent player who could contribute
right away but you look at
uh kids signing to oregon usc you can't
blame them but
i think unlv needs to focus on the ones
who are going to fresno state
that's a pier right colorado state
that's a pier two kids from the area are
going to colorado state and
unlv needs to focus on winning those
kids over all right you got to get the
best players in the mountain west thank
you much john appreciate that still
ahead on